with Brian's confidence slowly returning
now I've got to work on Sherita she
excels as a natural cook and a great
hostess but when it comes to business
she's a self-confessed numbskull but
it's not just the Takens that other
problem here 200 grams of butter like a
Beauty risen cake successful rationals
only thrive when three key business
factors are working in close harmony 200
grams of flour if we establish 1/3 staff
costs 1/3 food costs 1/3 gross profit
combine all those ingredients into one
recipe yeah chemistry you have the most
amazing cake and that's how any good
business works yeah
at the moment it's Rita's business cake
way of course I'll show you something
what we've got currently happening here
at the show with cue midweek customers
at Rita's gross profits are dangerously
low profit her food costs are reasonably
healthy but a massive overheads are
crippling her show that one's gonna cost
you when we start adding really high
staff costs so the balance already yep
bloody hard and I'm doing some purpose
to prove a point
yeah yeah you can't complete a recipe
for a successful business when you've
got imbalanced situation are you tell me
to [ __ ] off by how much you pay yourself
a month well I get around 200 a week
that's it I'm the lowest out of the
kitchen 200 pounds a week oh wait yeah
800 pounds in love you're working seven
days a week
that's a [ __ ] disgrace 780 it's more
than me some weeks a commie chef knows
part time gets paid more than you you're
far too [ __ ] soft
you really are far too soft yeah it
stops now
I know I know I know I know I know I
know
that is a profitable business and with
the right ingredients yeah that is what
you're currently running right have a
think let you know as we like to eat
why you crying truth is I'm not going to
do my business